ฮะ
โอเคสวัสดีค่ะคุณมิสวัสดีครับครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนะเรียนดีนักเรียนทุก
คนครับ 5 สวัสดีค่ะคุณนี้ก็พูดสุภาพคุณ
สุขภาพด้วยนะคะสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
พรุ่งนี้เสียงขู่เห็นดุกมากสวัสดีค่ะ
โอเคค่ะเดี๋ยวกูเอกเข้าแช่ screen ก่อนนะ
คะครูนี้เก้า
คนนี้ก็จะบอกกูเอาอันนี้ออก
คุณนี้คะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้ครับวันนี้
วันวันพฤหัสบดีวันพฤหัสบดีอาคา
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ที่เดี๋ยวนะคนนี้
ก็ต้องดูวันที่ 26 ครับวันที่ 26 นะคะ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมครับเดือน
พฤษภาคม
นิดมองเห็นนะคะน้องเห็นครับมองเห็นโอเคปี
พตเท่าไหร่คะมีผช
2565 ครับปีคศค่ะ
2022 ครับ 032 ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะที่
อเมริกาโอเคตอนนี้นะครับที่อเมริกาเวลา
9:00 น 9:00 นกับตอนเช้าครับ 9:00 นกี่
นาทีค่ะสี่ครับสี่นาทีนะคะตอนเช้ากูนิค
เพิ่งตื่นเพิ่งตื่นครับใจนี่ลืมตาแล้วนะ
ลืมแล้วใช่มะตาโทรมานะ
แอบมองเห็นตาครูนี่กับตาครูเอ๋ไหมคะเรามา
ทำตามโต 1 ต่อแล้วนะ
ถ้าคุณนิวันนี้นะเดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวก็ห้วยคู
นิกส์ยังไม่รู้ว่าที่ไทยกี่โมงเฮ้ย
แบบเรื่องจะมีเรื่องจะเล่าเนี่ยเลยพี่ปวย
Alert มาไทยที่ใครก็ 9:00 นไม่ใช่ 9:00
น 9:00 นโอเค 3 ทุ่มครับ
9:00 น 4 นาทีนะคะถ่ายกับข้างกับคุณนิ 12
ชั่วโมง
เวลาแต่งกันนะฮะครับ 2 ชั่วโมง
โอเคโอเค
คู๋มีมีอะไรครับ
เอาคุณครัวคุณนิดอยู่อเมริกาคุณนึกเล่า
เรื่องจีนแล้วใช่ไหมคะถ้าใครอยู่อเมริกา
เล่าเฮ้ย
รูไนะอยู่ไทยก็จะเล่าเราเรื่องไผ่นะคะ
ครูเอ๋มีเรื่องเล่าเกี่ยวกับเรื่องล่าง
เล่าคะกับคุณนิคะคุณนิครู้จักเดี๋ยวนะ
รู้จักคนนี้ไหมคะคนที่ 1 น่ะเดี๋ยวคนที่ 1
คนที่ 1 คนสายใช่ไหมครับคุณ nico  ex
เขียนเล็ก 1 นะโอเคครับเออ
คุณยึดวัดน่าจะใช่เช็คเสียหรือเปล่าโอ้ย
เก่งมากคุณนี้
โห
สุดยอด
เก่งมาก
พรุ่งนี้โป้
นักเรียนครูนิคกับครูเอ๋ไม่ได้เตรียมกัน
นะคุณเล็กไม่เคยเห็นก่อนเถอะกูเอกก็เอามา
ให้ดูแสดงว่ากูนี่เป็นแฟนคลับเช็คสเปียร์
เอ่อไม่ใช่ครับ
เดี๋ยวครูเอ๋รู้จักเรื่องเดียวโรมีโอกับ
จูเรียสเหมือนกันครับแต่คุณนี้กะเดาเดา
เอาว่าเป็นเช็คเปียเพราะว่าคุณนี่กะรู้
จักรูปด้านขวามือสองชายเบอร์ 2  shop ก็
เลยคิดว่าเอ๊ะถ้าครูเอ๋เอามาไว้ด้วยกัน
น่ะคนนี้น่าจะเป็นเช็คสเปียร์ขอ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
หนังเอกซ์ปีเข้าทำงานอะไรเช็คสเปียร์เขา
เป็นนักเขียนนักเขียนนะคะอ่ะราคาอ๊อดแล้ว
คนที่เบอร์ 2 ก็เป็นนักเขียนใช่ใช่ครับ
ถ้าถ้าครูนิคจำไม่ผิดนะคือสุนทรภู่ใช่ไหม
ครับใช่ค่ะอุ้ยเก่งอีกแล้วคู๋ยังไม่ถาม
ชื่ออะไรคนดิผมรูดชื่อสุนทรภู่ใช้ค่ะนี่
เป็นรูปปั้นของสุนทรภู่นะคะเป็นอะเรา
เรียกวันนัดกวีก็ได้เนาะใช่ๆต้องเรียกว่า
คือท่านนักเขียนนะเขียนเฉยๆแต่ถ้าเช็ค
สเปียร์กับสุนทรภู่น่ะเป็นนักกวีครับเช็ค
เขียนเรื่องที่เวลาอ่านแล้วก็
ดีมากนายมันซึ้งมันโอ๊ย
ภาษาที่เขียนน่ะก็สวยค่ะป 3 ภาษาสวยนะคะ
ถ้านักเรียนเรียนเรียนดีกินเอ้อเสร็จแล้ว
ไปอินเตอร์มีเดียเสร็จแล้วไปแอดวานซ์แล้ว
ก็ไป Super  advanced
เกิดก็จะเจอ
ทวียีสุนทรภู่เนาะได้ก็จะมีภาษาภาษาแบบ
สุนทรภู่ภาษาภาษาที่ครูเอ๋อ่านแล้ว
เป็นภาษาที่เราคนไทยเองเนี่ยบางทีดูแล้ว
ก็เอ๊ะคืออะไรแปลว่าอะไรอ่ะเล็กอ่านภาษา
ของสุนทรภู่เข้าใจ
100% ไหมคะไม่ครับ
คิดว่าประมาณ
60 เปอร์เซ็นต์อ่ะเอา 60 เปอร์เซนต์ก็
เก่งนะ
ครับคนที่เก่งนะคะ 60% ครูเองคิดว่า 50
บางบางอย่างเข้าใจบางอย่างยากภาษายากแต่
ว่า
อ่านแล้วก็รู้สึกดีก็ต้องคิดน้องมันดี
อะไรอร่อยๆครับ
โอเคค่ะนักเรียนทำไมเราพูดถึงสุนทรภู่พระ
สุนทรภู่เนี่ยเขียนวรรณคดีนะคะเราก็เรียก
คนที่เขียน
วรรณคดีว่า
กวีใช่คนอีกครับอ่ากวีซึ่งเช็คสเปียร์
เขียนวรรณคดีนะคะสุนทรภู่ก็เขียนวรรณคดี
ซีรีส์ครูเอ๋เอ๋กับครูนิก็จะมี
ก็จะมีจะมีวรรณคดีนิดหน่อยนะคะครับเราก็
จะคุยเกี่ยวกับวรรณคดีหรือเรือเรานิทาน
ไทยขับที่นี้ครูเอกก็มีสุนทรภู่แล้วนี่
คุยพาพาคุณขึ้นไปข้างบนก่อนานิประเทศไทย
ครับนะก็ตรงนี้จังหวัดอะไรคะคุณนี่
ครูนิคเนี่ยก็รักไม่มีแต่คุณนิคเดาว่า
ระยองเขาว่าคุณเห็นที่นี่ใช่ไหมใช่
ในรูปประเทศไทยแบบคุณอิ๊กมองไม่เห็นมัน
เล็กแต่ว่าขอโทษค่ะเพราะแต่ก็เห็นครูเอ๋
วางระยองข้างๆก็เลยอ่ะก็ต้องเป็นระยอง
แหละมันระยองใช่ไหมใช่โอเคโอเคโอเคอ่าอ่ะ
เห็นหรือยังระยองโอเค
ตี
กลับมาระยองโอเคโอเค
ค่ะจังหวัดระยองค่ะแล้วที่ระยองมีเกาะใช่
ไหมคะตรงนี้ขอบชุดเกาะอะไรคะอ๋ออ๋อเกาะ
เสม็ดใช่ไหมเกาะเสม็ดใช่ค่ะคูนิเคยไปเกาะ
เสม็ดไหมคะเคยครับเคยไปครับรับเคยไประยอง
ไปสิเนาะไปเสพจะเข้าไปต้องเข้าระยองก่อน
แล้วนั่งเรือไปหมดทำไมครูเอ๊ะถามคิดว่ากู
เอกง่วงนอน
ต้องระยองแล้วก็เกาะเสม็ดกูเอกต้องถามว่า
เคยไประยองมั้ยอ่ะเคยครับเอ้าแล้วไปเกาะ
เสม็ดไม้อันนี้โอเคใช่มั้ยใช่งูเอกข้าม
ค่าคำคำ Step ข้ามขั้นตอน
ถามเกาะเสม็ดก่อนนั้นก็ถามระยองมันได้นะ
ไม่ได้อ่ะฮะโอเคถ้าเคยไประยองเคยไปเกาะ
เสม็ดที่เกาะเสม็ดน่ะมีใช้ห่าตรงนี้ค่ะ
นักเรียนครับตรงที่คุยวงเอาไว้ตรงนี้ล่ะ
คะอะสีเขียวทัพ
รบเนี่ยค่ะอันเนี้ยชื่อหาดทรายแก้ว
คุณนิเคยไปไหมคะคุณนิคิดว่าคุณนิดจากเคย
ไปแต่แค่ไม่รู้ว่ามันเรียกว่าอะไรแต่คืน
เคยไปครับเพราะว่าคุณนิไปมาหลายทีละคำกู
เองไม่เคยไป
กูเอ๋ไประยองแต่ไม่เคยไปเกาะเสม็ดอ๋อ
ไม่เคยไปมิชอบนะไปเที่ยวกับเพื่อน - คุณ
นิคชอบชอบไปทะเล
เอกก็ชอบทะเลแต่ไม่ไปเกาะเสม็ด
ไปภูที่ 7  OK  I สิบพันโอเคไปอรุษเอา
โอเคไปเกาะเสม็ดไม่รู้ไม่ไปทำไมครับไม่
รู้อ่ะไม่ไม่เคยไปแต่ตั้งแต่เด็กๆที่บ้าน
ไม่ให้ไปเกาะเสม็ดเอกก็เลยไม่ไปแล้วทำไม
ไม่ให้ไปหน้าเมื่อก่อนไม่มีพายุอ๋ออ๋อ
ครับก็มีมีคลื่น
เมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมคะมีคลื่นค่ะหน้าแล้วก็
เรือน่ะเรือน่ะคว่ำก็
เรือล่มค่าเรือแบบนี้แล้วก็คว่ำเนี่ยเรา
พูดว่าเรือล่มลมบ่อยๆ
แต่ว่าไม่เป็นไรนักเรียนเกาะเสม็ดสวยนะคะ
นักเรียนก็จะหัวเราะหากครูเอ๋ฉันไปเกาะ
เสม็ดบ่อยๆครับพบเกาะเสม็ดจะได้ไม่ยาก
หรอกมันขับรถจากกรุงเทพฯประมาณสองสอง
ชั่วโมงไหม 3 ไหมวงประมาณนั้นครับใช่นั้น
ก็ขับรถไปเกาะเสม็ดก็ได้เนาะใช่ก็ขับรถไป
ที่ท่าเรือในระยองนะเรานั่งเรือมาที่เกาะ
เสม็ดชายที่นี้ถ้าคุณอีกเคยไปเกาะเสม็ด
คุณไม่เคยเห็นนั้นนี่ไหมคะเคยครับ
ใครเนี่ย
อันนี้เราเรียกว่าในทะเล
อันนี้หนังใช่ไหมครับจากนั้นค่ะ
เขาไม่มีกี่เที่ยวนะชื่อชื่อชื่อที่ขี่
เสื้อสมุทรเปิดใช่ๆใช่
มียักษ์มีรูปปั้นยักษ์นะมีเขี้ยวมาหา
ผีเสื้อสมุทรนะโอเคใส่เสื้อให้ไหมถ้า
เกิดลาย
นางยักษ์นาคาชื่อผีเสื้อสมุทรคนที่เคย
เห็นนะแล้วก็มีอันนี้ค่ะมีอะไรคะ
ใคร
นางเงือกใช่ไหมครับได้ค่ะนางเงือกตรงนี้
จะเป็นปลานะคะตอบ
เป็นปลาครึ่งบนเป็นคนเป็นผู้หญิงข้างล่าง
เนี่ยข้างล่างเป็นปลานะคะแล้วผู้ชายคนนี้
นะคะคุณนี้
คือพระอภัยมณีหรือเปล่าครับใช่ค่ะอุ้ย
เก่งยังจองได้ล่วงหน้าเลยเจ้าสร้างคุณ
ดิ๊กจำชื่อได้แต่ไม่แน่ใจป้าคุณละนี้คะ
พระอภัยมณีกำลังทำอะไรคะครับภัยมณีเป่า
ปี่ปี่ใช่ไหมค่ะเป่าปี่ในค่าอาอาแล้วก็
นั่งใช่มั้ยนั่งบนก้อนหินข้าวอะไรอันหิน
นะก็เป่าปี่
เดี๋ยวกูเอกให้ดูอีกคุยให้ดูภาพรู้จัก
ชื่อก่อนนะคะนักเรียนก็มีนางนางยักษ์ชื่อ
ผีเสื้อสมุทรสมุทรครับแล้วก็มีนางเงือกนะ
คะแล้วก็มีพระอภัยมณี
ราคาอันนี้ก็เป็นนางเงือกอีกนะคะที่เกาะ
เสม็ดมีนางเงือกเยอะนะ
คะแล้วก็มีนางเงือกนะคะแล้วก็มีลูกข่าว
ลูกหนังเนื้อนะคะ
ค่ะลูกชื่ออะไรนะครับสุดสุดๆ
สุดๆสา
สุดสาครหน้าสุดสาครแต่ว่าวันนี้เรายังไม่
พูดถึงสุดสาครนะคะ
อันนี้ขนาดเนื้อมี I  love เยอะเลยเนาะ
อือใช่ไม่เคยไปแต่เพิ่งเห็นน่ะมีนางเงือก
เยอะมากที่เกาะเสม็ดนักเรียนมาที่ระยอง
เองตัวเอกเคยไปที่นี่อ๋ออันนี้คุณอีกไม่
เคยไปอ่านในระยองค่ะในระยองก็จะมี
สุนทรภู่แล้วก็พระอภัยมณีนะคะ
แล้วก็มีรูปนี้ก็สุนทรภู่พระอภัยมณีนาง
เงือกนางยักษ์ชาวขีดพูด
นี่ก็คืออยู่ในระยองใช่ไหมครับได้หยุด
อยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะอนุสาวรีย์
ก็จะอยู่ก็คือจะมีมีอ่ะอ่ามี
สุนทรภู่
คืนนี้ก็ลุ้นว่ามีอะไร
ทอนพูดเนี่ยจะนั่งข้างบนโป้ขาสุนทรภู่
เป็นคนเขียนข่าวเรื่องพระอภัยมณีนะคะ
เลือกวันนี้ก็คุยก็จะเล่าเรื่องนี้แหละ
ค่ะเรื่องอีอยู่ว่าเรื่องพระอภัยมณีน่ะ
ครูนิครูเอ๋น่ะต้องเรียนนะคุณนี้ก็ต้อง
เรียนแต่คุณนิตัดหรือละใช่
วันที่แล้วก็ลืมเราจะจำที่เราชอบใช่ป่ะ
ตรงพระอภัยมณียาวก็จะจำนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อย
กูเอกก็จำได้
นิดหน่อยนะคะ
เฟิร์สแต่ว่าคุณอีกรู้ไหมทำไมเขาถึงมีมี
มีรูปปั้นพระอภัยมณีที่ระยอง
มากๆไม่มีที่อื่นนะ
คนนิดไม่แน่ใจแต่คู่นี้คิดว่าเพราะสุนทร
ภู่เกิดที่ระยองเก่ง
เอ้อ
ใช่ล็อคเขาเขียนเรื่องพระอภัยมณีก็เลย
ต้องมีรูปมีอะไรที่บอกว่าต้นกำเนิดอยู่
ที่นี่ซ้ายเพราะใช่ค่ะสุนทรภู่เป็นคน
ระยองค่ะ
พระอภัยมณีเรื่องมีอยู่ว่ากูอะเล่าเร็ว
ได้ใช่ครับนี่ก็มีในหลวงนะคะกับราชินี
ราชินีต้องผมยาวสิ
คุยใส่ผมให้
ราชินีอาจจะมัดผมอยู่ข้างบนตัวอยากให้ผม
ยาว
มีในหลวงกับราชินี
มีลูก 2 คนนะคะ
อ่ะลูกลูกคนโตนะคะลูกคนที่ 1 เนี่ยชื่อ
ขอพระอภัยมณี
ครับ
ลูกคนที่ 2 เนี่ยชื่อศรีสุวรรณช็อปค่ะ
คุณนิคนะเพราะมีลูก 2 คนอะในหลวงกับ
ราชินีน่ะพ่อลูกสองคนโตโตๆก็อยากให้ลูก
น่ะเก่งขอส่งลูกไปเรียน
ถ้าตอนนี้ก็ไปเรียนโรงเรียนไปเรียน
มหาวิทยาลัย
แสตมป์เมื่อก่อนนี้เขาต้องเข้าไปในภูเขา
คุณไม่บอกเห็นนะคะครับไม่ได้ป่า
ก็ไปเรียนอะไรในป่าในภูเขาครับมีมี
อาจารย์มีฤาษีค่ะโอเค
มีฤาษีใช่ไหมคะฤาษีกับนะครับ
ฤาษีหนวดยาวๆๆ
เขามีฤๅษีนะสอนขอพระอภัยมณีกับศรีสุวรรณ
น่ะไปนะคะไปที่เขาเรียกอาสงฆ์บ้านของเล่น
สีคือสีกับกับฤาษีก็ถามอย่าเรียนอะไร
อยากเรียนอะไรพระอภัยมณีน่ะชอบฟังเพลง
พระอภัยมณีบอกว่าขอเรียนเป่าปี่อืออันนี้
เป็นปี่
แล้วก็เป่าปีกไม่เป่าขลุ่ยเป่าปี่อัลบี่
สิอะไรเพราะว่าถ้าคุยเนี่ยมันจะไม่มีไอ้
ที่ข้างบนตรงนี้นะครับค่ะเรียนเป่าปี่นะ
คะเออครูนิคเป่าปี่ได้ไหมคะ
เออเอ่อคุณดิ๊กเนี่ยไม่เคยเป่าปี่นะแต่
คุณนิเคยเป่าขลุ่ย
คุยไม่มีวันนี้น้องไม่มีอันนี้แล้วตรงนี้
ไม่รู้ครับใช่
คุณนี้ก็เป่าไม่เก่งนะ
กูเองไม่ได้
มาพระอภัยมณีไปเรียนเป่าปี่ค่ะคุณนี้
โอเคเพราะว่าชอบฟังเพลงใช่ไหมชายส่วนศรี
สุวรรณไปเรียน
ไม้พองกระบี่กระบองต่อสู้ใช่ไหมครับก็ไม่
เชิงต่อสู้จะเป็นไม้
หน้าเป็นไม้เขาเขาไม่ได้คือเขาเขาไม่ได้
เรียนดาบอะ
จริงพ่อพ่อก็คิดว่าอยากจะให้เรียน
จากเรียนเรียนดาบเรียนต่อยมวยเรียนดาบนะ
คะแต่ว่าพระอภัยมณีก็เรียนต่อปีอ่ะศรีโรง
เรียนลำไม้ผีก็บอก
ไม่ได้ต่อยไม่ได้ฟันดาบคะ
พอ
เกาะพระโอรส ๒ พระองค์เนี่ยขับลูกพระราชา
ลูกพระราชินีเรียกว่าพระโอรสนะครับเรียน
เสร็จก็กลับมา
กลับมาบ้าน
พ่อกับแม่ก็บอกอ้ะเรียนอะไรมาไหน
คำให้ดูครับอยากเห็นอยากเห็นแอบพระ
อภัยมณีเกาะเป่าปี่
อ่ะศรีสุวรรณก็ลำลำไม้รํากระบี่กระบอง
กระบองเนาะตายรำกระบอง
คุณนี้ขาถ้าคุณนี้เป็นพ่อปวดหัวไหมคะ
ถ้าเฟอร์เนื้อเพลงจริงๆเป็นคนไทยก็จะปวด
หัวนะจะเป็นพ่อคนอะไรไปเรียนมาทำไมมันไม่
เห็นเจอมีประโยชน์
เธอเป็นประเภทนักเรียนโอเคเลยนะลูกชอบอัน
นี้เป่าขลุ่ยไวโอลีนครับมีเลยแต่ที่ไทย
เมื่อก่อนนะสมัยอะไรเธอทำไมไปเรียนอะไร
แบบนี้มันไม่ดีมันไม่มีประโยชน์ใช่แบบถ้า
ปี 2022 เนี่ยโอเคค่ะครับโอเคตอนนี้โอเค
เรียนดนตรีระบบเรียนดนตรีโอเค
คุณนิขา
พอโปรดมาก
โอเคแล้วทำยังไงครับพี่
ออกไป
ไล่ลูกออกจากบ้านในลูกหมู่บ้านเลย
อะไรลูกออกจากบ้านไปน่ะก็ปรากฏว่า
คุยว่าเป็นตัวการ์ตูนง่ายๆได้ไหมคะครับ
พอไล่ออกจากบ้านไปล่ะก็
กลับแต่ลูกมีเพื่อนมาด้วยนะมีเพื่อนใหม่
อีก 2 โอเคก็ไปเขาก็ไปเดินเดินไปริมทะเล
ครับทะเลมีต้นไม้
ลิปพระอภัยมณีก็มีก้อนหินเธอพาไปมณีก็
นั่ง
อ่ะศรีสุวรรณก็นั่งที่นี่
แล้วก็มีพองไม้แล้วก็เพื่อนใช่ไหม
4  4 คนค่ะปีสุวรรณเนี่ยลูกคนที่สองนะคะ
กับลูกคนที่ 1 ศรีสุวรรณ
ทำไมพ่อไม่เข้าใจ
เสือร้องไห้เสียใจเพราะว่าโดนไล่ออกจาก
บ้านใช่ๆทุกคนเสียใจเราครับพระอภัยมณีก็
เลยเอาปี่น่ะขึ้นมาคุยกับพี่ก่อน
นะคะพระอภัยมณีก็
ลืม
นางจะมีพระอภัยมณีก็เป่าปี่ต่อปีพระ
อภัยมณีปี่พระอภัยมณีดีมากนะคุณนี้คือ
เป่าแล้วแรกก็รู้ว่าน้องแล้วก็อีก 2 คน
อ่ะเสียใจไม่สบายใจนอนไม่ได้
ค่าภัยมณีก็เป่าปี่ให้
น้องเนี่ย
นอน
นอนหลับนะคะชอบพอน้องและข้อ 3 คนหมอจะนัด
ทั้งหมดตรงเนี้ยเขา
สองคนก็นอนหลับป่ะหลับด้วยโอเคสุวรรณก็
นอนหลับตาตอนที่กำลังเป่าเปียกคุณเอ๊ะ
ก็อีกจะเอามาได้ไหมนางยักษ์
นางยักษ์กูอีกอยู่ไหนนี้แล้วกันนางยักษ์
นางยักษ์ชื่ออะไรนะคะกี่เสื้อสมุทรครับ
การได้ผีเสื้อสมุทรเนี่ยก็
อยู่ตรงนี้แล้วกัน
ผีเสื้อสมุทรก็ได้ยิน
ได้ยินเสือสมุทรออกมาหาปลาได้ยิน
ได้ยินเสียงขลุ่ยเสียงก็มีครับเอ้ยขอโทษ
ค่ะก็
ขอบคุณเด็กปีได้เข้าไปปีซึ้ง
ได้ยินเสียงปี่
นางยักษ์เกาะเดินๆมาแล้วก็แอบดู
โอเคแอบดูก็เห็นโอ้พระอภัยมณีรอครับชอบ
ไหมชอบสิชอบภาพนางยักษ์ก็เลย
พี่
ขอ
เสกคาถาหรอครับให้พระอภัยมณีนอนหลับก็
โอเค
ให้ทุกคนหลับนานๆครับแล้วนางยักษ์นี่ค่ะ
นี่นี่กูอีกวาดไว้เหมือนไหมเหมือน ok  ok
โอ้นางยักษ์เกาะกุมพระอภัยมณีไปอ๋อองไป
ที่ไหนครับขออุ้มไปที่
มีเกาะ
นะคะมีเกราะ
แล้วข้างในนะมีถ้ำ
ทำ
ครับที่ทะเลนะคะนางยักษ์ก็อุ้มพระอภัยมณี
มาที่นี่อะมีเตียงนอนด้วยก็ให้นอน OK
นอนนะคะส่วนนางยักษ์ก็
เปลี่ยนตัวเองเขาเป็นผู้หญิงตัวเล็กๆเออ
โอ่ง Pink เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนเนาะ
เปลี่ยน
ผู้หญิงสวยไหวโอเคครับคุณนิพระอภัยมณีนะ
นอนหลับรถตื่นขึ้นมาเห็นแต่ผู้หญิงสวยก็
ชอบนะชอบเลยก็โอม
จงชอบฉันชอบฉันเจอเศษคาท้ายอีกแล้ว
พระอภัยมณีกับนางยักษ์ God แต่งงานกัน
ครับ Happy  Ending ใช่ไหมก็เหมือนจะ
Happy  Ending นะแต่คิดว่ามันต้องมีอะไร
อีกถ้าเพราะยังยังไม่เห็นนางเงือกเลยเอา
อย่างเงี้ยน้ำยาก็ท้องค่ะ
นางยักษ์เนี่ยนางยักษ์คนนี้นะคะก็ท้อง
ท้อง
แล้วก็คลอดลูกครับ
ลูกเป็นผู้ชาย
ผู้ชายอ่ะนางยักษ์ก็ให้ชื่อว่าสินสมุทร
ฮะโอเคสมุดครับนี้จำได้แล้วใช่มั้ยอ้ะ
แป๊บๆนางยักษ์อ่ะชอบกินกินสัตว์ใหญ่ๆงั้น
น่ะทุกๆ 7 วันทุกๆ 15 วันนางยักษ์ก็ต้อง
ไปข้างนอกจับปลา
จับช้างครับอันนั้นใช่แม่นเห็นช้างไหมคะ
โอเคครับเหมือนไหมเมื่อได้ได้ชัดครับครับ
ครับก็กดมากสินสมุทรเนี่ยพอโตโตเร็วมาก
ครับโตเร็วออกพระอภัยมณีคุยมาที่นี่ละกัน
ชาว
อันนี้เปลี่ยนเป็นบ้านนั่งอยากดีกว่าเนาะ
โอเคพระอภัยมณีอะ Copy มาจาก
มีพระอภัยมณีน่ะอยู่บ้านก็เป่าปี่น้องชอบ
เป่าปิด
ค่าภัยมณีก็เองทำไมลูกแข็งแรงข่าวแล้วสิน
นางยักษ์เวลาไปนะคุณนี้เขาจะมีก้อนหินปิด
ตรงนี้เอาไว้ขอเพราะไม่อยากให้เห็นใช่ไหม
ไม่ให้ออกไปข้างนอก
พระอภัยมณีก็อยู่ในถ้ำมานานหลายปีคำ
หลายปีหรือไม่รู้กี่ปี
แล้วกอล์ฟสิงห์สมุทรโตแต่โตเร็วมากยัง
เล็กๆนะอายุ 1 ปี 2 ปี 3 ปีแต่งแรงเราก็
ตัวโตๆเร็วคาวะคนครึ่งยักษ์
ฟินสมุดก็พ่อไปข้างนอกฉาบพ่อพระอภัยมณีก็
บอกว่าไปไม่ได้ประตูปิดตอบ
โอ๊ยลูกอยู่ที่นี่แหละกับพระอภัยมณีก็นอน
หลับ
สินสมุทรก็มาที่นี่โอเค
แล้วก็
ออกได้อ๋ออ๋อเอาก้อนหินออกกายออกได้แพง
not
แล้วก็ไปเจอ
เจอนางเงือกชอบที่คุนนี่บอกหลังเลือกอยู่
ที่ไหนใช่ไหม
ไปเจอไปเจอเจอนางเงือกอุ้ยว่าหน้ากันง่าย
กว่า
เจอนางเงือกนางเงือก 3 ตัวค่ะ 3 ตัวโอเค
ครับมีพ่อ
มีแม่นะคะมีพ่อแม่น้ำเงือกด้วยนะคะแล้วก็
นางยักษ์กลับมาอากลับมาก็จึงจะหมดจริงๆ
จับนางเงือกไปตัวอย่างเงือกก็เลยช่วยด้วย
ช่วยด้วยอ๋อโอเคอ๋อโดนจับขับไล่จับพระ
อภัยมณีก็ช่วยนางเงือกบอกไม่เอาไม่เอาไป
แกล้งเขานะคะแล้วที่สุดพระอภัยมณี
สินสมุทรก็รู้ว่าแม่เป็นยักษ์
โอเคก็ต้องรอกับคุณนิรอจนอีกอาจจะ 7 วัน
15 วันเหตุครับอีก 1 เดือนไม่รู้นาง
ยักษ์ออกไปครับ
ก็ก็สินสมุทร
เงือกก็ผ่าพระอภัยมณีหนีค่ะก็มีออกไปความ
แม่เป็นเอ่อผีเสื้อสมุทรในเป็นยักษ์แล้ว
กลัวใช่ไหมครับลอยเสร็จแล้วนี่ๆหนีออกไป
ใช่ไหมคะนี่ที่เป็นรูปนี้อ่ะค่ะอ่ะจะหนี
มานั่งยักษ์เนี่ยเหมือนจะรู้ใช่ไหมคะ
นางยักษ์ก็ตามแนวเหนือเอกขึ้นไปก่อน
แผนที่นี่หนิที่นักเรียนเห็นนะคะอันนี้
ครับนางยักษ์ก็ตามตามมาเพราะว่าเขาหนีมา
จนถึงเกาะ
เกาะนึงนะคะ
นางยักษ์ว่าตามมาแต่ว่านางยักษ์ขึ้นเกาะ
ไม่ได้
ทำไมครับอ่อที่เกาะมีมีพระฤาษี
โอเคครับ
ที่เกาะมีพระฤๅษี
พระฤๅษีน่ะไม่ให้ขึ้นแม่นางยักษ์นะฆ่าพ่อ
แม่ของเลือกกินเลยโว้โอโอ้โอมีเงือกเงือก
ผู้หญิงน่ะก็เลยเสียใจเลยนะเพราะว่ามีคน
ยักษ์เนี่ยฆ่าพ่อแม่ตัวเองแม่ของเลือกได้
แล้วก็ยักษ์จะเข้ามาเนี่ยพระอภัยมณี
กระเป๋าปี่
เดี๋ยวก็ Oil เจ็บเจ็บคอโอเคก็มาไม่ได้
ได้คือพระอภัยมณีอ่ะเป่าปีกให้คนฟังนอน
หลับได้ครับเป่าปีให้คนร้องไห้เสียใจ
ไม่สบายใจหายไปได้โอเคแล้วก็เป่าปี่ให้
ปวดหัวได้โอเคโอเค
นะคะอันนี้พระอภัยมณีกับสินสมุทรแล้วก็
นางเงือกก็หนีนางยักษ์ได้ค่ะได้มาอยู่ที่
เกาะที่มีหรือทรายคายนะคะแต่วันนี้นะทั้ง
หมดแล้วค่ะเราก็เล่าถอดนึงของพระอภัยมณี
ใครนะฟังเวลานักเรียนไประยองจะได้อ๋อหนู
จะ
รู้แล้วว่าอ้อมีเรื่องแบบนี้ที่ระยองครับ
เรามีผีเสื้อสมุทรใช่ไหมคะ
มีพระอภัยมณีมีอะไรคะนางเงือก
แล้วก็มีสุนทรภู่
ใช่ครับอันนี้ก็เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับที่
ระยองเนาะค่ายผู้คือใครรักมีเรื่องเกี่ยว
กับพระอภัยมณีใช่พระอภัยมณีคือใครก็เอา
ช็อตหนึ่งนะคะนักเรียนเข้าจริงๆยาวมาก
ยาวมากบีกินเนอร์ฟังนิดหน่อยโอเคโอเคได้
หมดเวลาแล้วเลยเวลาแล้วตอบ OK ได้ครับไว้
ครั้งต่อไปก็นักเรียนรอดูว่าเราสองคนเนาะ
จะคุยจะเล่าเรื่องอะไรให้สั่งได้ค่ะคลิป
นี้กลัวเอกกับคนนี้ไปก่อนนะคะนายครับไว้
เจอกันใหม่ครับพี่เอ๋เอ๋สวัสดีครับสวัสดี
ค่ะบ๊ายบายค่ะอ่ะ